[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the 10 secrets
to be able to increase your user
retention of your application
I'm very surly product manager at Google
focused on improving the quality of the
Android ecosystem I'm Joe caster ennum
with the Google Play BD team and I'm
Ricardo engineering manager in Google
Play so today we're going to spend some
time together to understand how the Play
console can help you create great apps
that captivate your users and achieve
great user retention to do that we're
going to spend a good amount of time
thinking about performance we're going
to focus on a performance and technical
quality and we're going to look at out
that you can achieve that throughout
Europe lifecycle finally we're going to
look at our play is going to reward all
of you as developers for focusing on a
performance and technical quality first
so Y will focus on a performance why
does it matter and the reason is pretty
simple some people say that there is
enough for everything thing is there is
not high performing app for everything
and high performing apps achieve and
great and high user retention and that's
why performance matters a high quality
app that doesn't crush and doesn't
stutter is critical to achieve that high
user retention users love these great
experiences and they have no reason to
leave when they have a great performing
gap for us developers is a great
differentiator from other apps they may
offer similar functionality to yours
couple of numbers that you may have seen
we have shown them earlier today but
here is some data points that's just Y
creating a high quality app matters
summarizing if you create an app that
doesn't really perform that well users
are going to notice and they're going to
mention it in their reviews other users
are going to see it and this is going to
spread around when we look at reviews
that have been written in the Play Store
50% of the time
people left the one star they were
mentioning stability and badging there
60% of the time they were living you
five stars it was because you focused on
speed usability design and all these
great things we asked a few developers
around and here is one that we also
showed yesterday buzu which is a
language learning app which is used
worldwide made a big big investment on
performance it's part of that culture
and they with that focus and focusing on
the technical performance of the wrap
they improve their star rating from four
point one to four point five stars which
is a pretty big jump if you think about
it so we're going to focus and walk
through a few features on how you go
focus on a few features that are going
to help you create high quality apps
throughout the lifecycle of your
development from before the launch so
when you're go about to go live - when
you are fully live and you want to
understand and iterate your app
performance and these are going to be
aware of 10 secrets so the first one
they are going to mention before launch
is the pre-launch report we mentioned it
today in the keynote it's there in the
play in Playstation pre-launch report
summarizes issues that we found when
testing Europe automatically against the
collection of physical Android devices
we think that is already greatly
contributing to the success of apps and
already thousands of developers are
using that pre-launch report behind the
scene is powered by the firebase test
lab for Android is basically our data
center pipe full of Android devices
where you can test your app pre-launch
report does it automatically if you want
to do your own custom testing custom
scripts and such you can integrate with
the firebase test lab for Android and
run your own custom scripts against
physical devices from Android studio
from your continuous build and such key
part of pre-launch report that you can
find in the flight console is what we
call apps stability testing we have a
robot crawler that automatically rolls
and plays with your app for every apk
that you upload to the alpha or beta
Channel in the fly console it close the
app autumn
tickle it for five minutes and it tells
you if you detect any crushes and get
the little red indications there which
means that if the robot detects a crush
when your apk was in alpha emitter it's
a crush they didn't reach production
because you can then fix it before your
app goes to product and your users will
not leave a one-star review because of
that vast majority of flight top
developers have adopted the playrooms
report since when we launched it last
year and since then we've performed over
six point five million crawls over one
hundred and thousands of apks these
numbers are ninth but the best one is
the impact for users 85% of the time
when the pre-launch report detected a
crash the app was not then later
launched to production and this means
that millions of users has been spared
from a crash that would have otherwise
affected them the first big change and
announcement is we are making today is
this one you may have heard obviously
about Android oh and the latest
Developer Preview and such so it took a
bunch of pixels phones and along with
all the devices we made them available
to you in the pre-launch report you can
now test very easily how your app
performs on Android Oh it just have to
upload an apk to the alpha or beta
channel in play in the play console and
by the end of this thought or by the end
of tonight dinner or the concert you get
the results back and you get to see how
your app perform when executing against
Android oh so this was super number one
Android overview available in the
products report for all of you starting
now
second secret is more pre-launch report
features not only we had more devices we
invest also in the functionality that it
offers to allow the robot to crawl more
of your app with data that you control
you can now specify tests Prudential's
that the robot will use to pass through
login screens and explore more of your
app behind those login screens we've
improved the way the robot captures
fringes and videos during the crawl
specifically we now take into account
the structure of Europe the activity
that is composed of and the transition
during to plus the screenshots
intelligently so you get to see at a
glance all your different parts that
they are look and feel which is kind of
useful if you want to spot if you have
for example visual inconsistencies
across formal factors or across
languages and finally we also
automatically scan Europe for
vulnerabilities and privacy leaks we
added a bunch of scans and new detectors
over the last year so now we capture up
to think thirty new so the different
type of vulnerabilities and privacy
issues be the usage of outdated
libraries that have known problems or be
coding patterns that you have that
result in leaking identifiers so if
you've not already given it a try
you can go to the Play console now opt
into the pre-launch report and the next
apk you will upload to alpha and beta
will undergo all these treatments and
analysis number of developers like pol
co played Amex I found it is really
helpful to give them that sense of
security to go to production safely so
definitely consider giving in to thrive
and so this is secret number two more
features in the pre-launch report the
next step is you're about to go live and
you want to make you have to make
distribution decisions the moment when
you go live is one of the most critical
in your app lifecycle because the one
this is when your users will discover
your app or your new features for the
first time an Android today gives you an
amazing reach thanks to the diversity of
Android devices cross capabilities and
price points but we heard from many of
you that navigating the device phase and
the targeting the right devices can be a
bit of a challenge and so we have made a
number of changes as you may have heard
yesterday we created a brand new device
catalog in the play console you go from
the long list of checkboxes that you
have on one side to a full feature
device catalog across the thousand of
devices that you can target
not just nice to look at there is a
bunch of things that they can do for you
first for each device you get full
device fax Ram GPU system-on-chip screen
size OS version and everything we also
group different models that different
SKUs that belong to the same model so
you can see all the common devices in
one group you can search by spec you can
search for example for all devices that
have a given characteristic like I think
it missed a couple of gigs of RAM and
for every search or slice that you
create we tell you how many
installations are much which rating and
how much revenue is coming from that
particular slice what we use that for is
that for what we call device exclusion
rules you can now choose to target your
application to a selection of devices
under your control for example if you're
developing a rich graphics game you may
choose to develop the target only
devices that have at least 1 gigabyte of
RAM because that is the minimum under
which your game will run respectively
you can also set similar exclusion rules
for example on system-on-chip
because maybe you have detected a
particular issue with the system
ownership and you want to temporarily
limit distribution to those devices
until you get a fix and you can resume
distributing to those whenever you
create an exclusion rule we tell you
exactly how many users are much rating
and how much revenue is going to be
affected by excluding those devices so
you can make this decision consciously
and know whether it's worth doing it or
not finally we've updated the play
console throughout so from many
different places in the play console you
can link straight into the device
catalog be from reviews we from the
start pages and such so this is secret
number three brand new device catalog
and targeting capabilities the last one
that I want to mention briefly and you
may avert in a session later early today
is a brand new release dashboard until
now looking at statistics in the flight
console was a bit sad because you get
limited analytics
abilities and they only updated once a
day and sometime it would take two days
so we decided to change that a lot you
get a brand-new release dashboard an
associative statistics that update by
the hour and capture all the significant
information that describe your
application stages be it crushes ratings
installation and installations as they
happen so you can monitor your releases
while they are in progress for key
information like ratings and crashes and
reviews they come in real time so you
can detect the moment you release goes
out if there is a problem coming and you
can take action immediately
and so this was number four a brand new
real-time monitoring dashboard for urine
leaders Fergus George good great so we
talked about before released during
relief now we're going to talk about the
data from the field how it can be able
to use that to be able to improve the
quality of your application the first
area to talk about here is reviews so we
relaunched reviews analysis last year at
Google oil this enables you to be able
to see what topics people are talking
about in your reviews and how those
topics are having a positive or negative
impact on your rating in the store this
is where put in Google's machine
learning teams to work for you to be
able to extract those topics and they'll
to also see how you're comparing with
other apps in your category with the
peer benchmarks that we offer now up
until today it was only available in
English now we're making it available in
the second most popular language on
Google Play which is Spanish another
major market for play developers is
Japan so we're also enabling to be able
to see the topics that people are
talking about in Japanese
one of the big limitations that people
have had with interacting with users on
Google Play and responding to reviews is
that we haven't had a full review
history when a user would update their
review you wouldn't be able to see the
previous review that they've written now
we're enabling you to be able to see the
full thread of the history of any
communication you've had and they had
with you in our review section if the
user deletes their whole review you
won't see the history of course but if
they keep changing their reviews you can
be able to have a fluid conversation
with them now developers have been
getting great results from reviews we've
seen a 50 percent increase in the number
of developer responses over the past
year and the reason they're doing is
that and interacting with reviews is
because they see users increase in their
star rating as a result we now have an
updated rating section in the play
console where you can be able to see
what is the change in rating that users
are doing if they if you reply to them
and what is the change in rating if you
haven't replied to them and you can be
able to make the decision yourself as to
whether this is a wise investment of
your time to be able to respond to
reviews finally the last big addition to
the reviews area that we're announcing
today is the ability to be able to flag
reviews so we do a lot of evaluation on
the reviews when they're posted on
Google Play
sometimes reviews that don't match our
posting guidelines get through our
evaluation and if you think that one of
the reviews does not match our posting
guidelines that you can be able to let
us know and we'll do another manual
review and evaluation of the review and
determine whether we should remove it or
not this is already thank you
again so this has already been rolled
out to a few developers and it will be
rolled out to all the play developers
over the next couple of months so stay
tuned for that so that's the fifth
seekers reviews and focusing on your
reviews and the reviews analysis and
reviews management tools that we have
available to you now let's jump into the
sixth siegrist which is android vitals
Android BIOS was featured in the keynote
yesterday it's a big initiative at
Google to be able to improve the
stability and performance of apps across
the whole Android ecosystem the first
thing we're doing is focusing on three
core core performance areas those are
stability render time and battery
however you'll see a lot more
performance areas being provided to you
over the course of the next year we just
launched the Android bio section in the
Play Developer console this is where you
can go and see today the data on your
application from the users who have
opted in so where does it say to come
from this data is generated from the
hundreds of millions of users who have
opted in to share their device usage in
Diagnostics data with Google and our
partners you so we're now making that
available to you for the first time and
we're very excited for you to be able to
use this data and improve your apps as a
result you do not need to use an SDK to
get this data you do not need to change
your app at all you just need to go to
the Play Developer console and look at
this data now we're going to making a
lot of data available here for the first
time and we think this is going to
change the dynamics within companies in
terms of how they look at performance up
until now
very few people within the company have
seen the performance data on their
application because they aren't running
Android studio themselves and look in
that performance data now that we're
exposing that in the Play console your
product manager your other engineers
that you work with can be able to see
that data and could be able to make the
choice of whether you should invest in
improving performance or building that
latest feature now to make it really
actionable for you we have generated
concepts of bad behaviors this is where
if you're in the bottom 25% for any one
of these metrics we will flag that to
you and put a red exclamation mark on
your application this alerts you that
this is an area where you should really
invest in because you're underperforming
compared to your peers
so this talk is about user retention and
here's a quote from the Kabam team of
how much they user retention has
improved as a result of their focusing
on performance and so we hope that all
of you will make performance a big part
of your culture and your app development
for us in the future
great so now we're going to jump into
three other secrets that are all tied
together and I'm going to draw an
analogy here to at triathlons I
completed a couple of triathlons myself
and when you are training for a
triathlon and you improve in one sport
you increase your fitness you increase
your performance into other sports as
well and that's where by improving in
one performance area you'll probably see
input informants improvements into other
areas but you still need the knowledge
and equipment to be successful in each
one individually so I hope you connect
with the analogy so let's jump into the
first sport only joking the first bad
performance area here so stability so
stability is all about providing a
reliable experience your users and we
are providing a lot of insights here
that you might not have been able to get
from other crash reporting tools and why
would you care about this area so what
we found is that making a first
impression on users is critical as we
all know and that the data shows that if
your app crashes loss on the first day
of use you get 30% more uninstallation
than if your app works well so really
focusing on these stability issues it's
critical to use ways as I mentioned this
is data from the Android vitals is from
users who have opted in previously the
data that has been in the crashes main
or section of the play console has come
from users individually reporting events
now that we have this data from the
opposite end users you can expect to see
about a 100 X increase in the crash data
in the play console and so that could
give you a lot better coverage and a lot
better insights into your app
performance while still covering 98% of
Android versions
now I'm sure all of you are aware of the
crashes and and crash for user race and
all a plot of things
Ian ores are critical thing to focus on
on Android as well
Canadian or is application now
responding this is when your application
is frozen for more than five seconds in
the Android bio section we show you
broken down by aspersion by device and
by Android version
what is your a and our race then you can
click on let's say the a in our is from
a specific app version and you could be
able to go in and see all the a in our
clusters corresponding to that version
and you can be able to then go in speak
click on a specific cluster and be able
to view the tread rooms and other
diagnostics information about the
devices etc to be able to really focus
on fixing that issue you can also be
able to access the previous data source
that we had for a in origin crashes in
the play console if you'd like to see
that data as well
Twitter has built a phenomenal
application it has a amazing reliable
experience however they were even able
to learn things from the A&R data in the
play console when we gave them early
access to this and they were able to fix
issues already with their applications
as a result so I encourage you all to go
and check out this section and see what
you can fix to recap in the stability
area we have two core things to focus on
here reducing your a and/or raise and
reducing your crash rate next we're
going to jump into rendering so
rendering is about providing a fluid
experience to your users and having it
so that they feel like they're getting a
60 frames per second experience on their
device 60 frames per second results in
draw events happening every 16
milliseconds so if you miss one of these
draw events your app starts to feel
lagging
even if you miss it by just one
millisecond then you've missed that
frame and appears it's 32 million
seconds until that frame is redrawn if
you miss multiple events then it really
appears like it's a slow experience for
the users and a half has nearly even
become frozen to a lesser extent than an
aien or what's still not responding to
their input and this is about 700
milliseconds what we found we now give
you the insights into these as this data
in the play console in terms of render
times we show you the distribution of
render times and we show you the
potential root causes of why these
things are happening so you can be able
to figure out if it's something to do
with things happening on the UI thread
the two core metrics to look at in terms
of render time are slow rendering and
frozen frames so slow rendering is when
the percentage of users who have
experienced more than 50% of their
frames render decorating than 16
milliseconds frozen frames is when 0.1%
of your users have experienced more than
more 0.1% of your use of the frames how
to render raise up greater than 700
milliseconds
great so now we've covered the eight
secrets we're going to jump into the
ninth secret here now which is battery
so we all want to be able to have
battery life lasts for the entire day
and we all as app developers want to
reduce our usage on the battery when
it's unnecessary and this is where we're
now going to start telling you when we
think you are actually using the battery
unnecessarily this includes using the
radios and the CPU the first one is
wakelocks this is where when the device
is idle you're keeping a wakelock
for more than an hour in the Android bio
section each metric that I'm talking
about for the bad behaviors here has a
separate way for you to be able to
diagnose and investigate the data for
the way clocks we provide you the
wakelock name and you can be able to
figure out where there is an issue there
with a specific way clock and go and
investigate that specific one we also
link out from each of the performance
areas to articles on the
developer.android.com documentation so
you can be able to understand each one
of these way clocks as well the way
clocks that you use within your
application should not be completely
unique per user because otherwise you
won't be able to get the aggregated view
of them we also have it broken down by
app version as you can see here and then
you can be able to see the distribution
of wakelocks finally the last metric
they're introducing is wake up so wake
ups are when you are constantly waking
up the device when the device is idle so
we slide your application when you wake
the application of more than 10 times
per hour and you have a high percentage
of users who are impacted by that this
is another tablet in the console we give
you the wakeup tagnames here as well so
you can be able to figure out where the
issue is the two battery areas to look
at stock way clocks and extensive wake
up's incur
check those out and figure out where you
are having an issue in your application
potentially and as that we will flag you
with a red marker if you're in the
bottom 25% of apps for each one of these
metrics so you know to look into that
area go ahead now going to hand over to
Joe to reveal actually one sec I've got
some bonus actually a secrets for you
guys just on the Android vital side so
we have many resources outside of the
Play console to help you with improving
your performance the first one is to use
developers Android calm ones
documentation on the performance areas
in general some of the videos and from
the Play console we linked out to the
relevant ones as well next is to use
Android studio profilers that have been
built into Android view 3.0 which was
launched yesterday
and finally firebase performance
monitoring is an SDK that you can
include in your application so you don't
just look me to look over the whole apk
you can look diagnosed specifically
within your apk within a specific part
of the apk if there's an issue and you
can be able to instrument the
application yourself out of the box
comes networking startup time where
there are counters so you can be able to
set it up whatever way you like now
we're going to hand it over to Joe for
the final secret on rewards all right so
now it's time for the best part so why
should you care why should you jump on
this now well reducing your one-star
rating is reducing your run installs
they'll seem like pretty compelling
reasons those in addition to the things
that Ricardo alluded to earlier like
reducing you're getting a more stable
app leading to better user experience
leading to stronger engagement longer
retention all these are really good
reasons but there's actually directly
impact for reasons that relate to your
app and its presence and his performance
in the Play Store this relates to place
received quality of your app and the
promote ability that goes with it plays
always strive to surface the highest
quality as for our users and your app
health is a key component to signal for
that app health is important for your
your search results in the store it's
important for the promotional and
merchandising collections in the store
app health is also important for awards
designations and collections like
editor's choice and the Google Play
Awards so getting your app health right
is one of the most fundamental things
developers can do to focus to be
successful and play play takes in
various user signals to determine and
apps promote ability and which and the
app vitals point directly in to that for
example if an app crashes often it could
use it it could lead to a user having a
really poor experience they could
probably want to believe in you app or
review you get more one star ratings
they could even lead to lower usage and
even uninstall all of this can
negatively impact your promote ability
and your presence in the Play Store so
developing high quality apps actually
acts as like a virtuous cycle to where
you have a better user experience you're
going to get better user reviews those
better user reviews and ratings will get
you better results and promote ability
within the store which will drive more
users etc the new and updated future
collection this has been a longtime
favorite of our users and developers in
the Play Store and frankly it's a
favorite of the play team as well
because it's a great place to showcase
the highest quality apps and games that
are launching underneath given a week in
the store as you can imagine app quality
has been a key foundational factor when
reviewing apps and determining their
eligibility for consideration in this
collection and as you can imagine these
new app final metrics that we're talking
about are going to plug into this app
quality review that we do on the apps
and then finally we have the Google Play
Awards these celebrate the achievements
of our developer community over the past
year by recognizing the best apps and
games across twelve categories this year
we've introduced new categories to fully
reflect the breadth of apps and games
that deliver innovative experiences in
the Play Store we evaluate games on we
value a both the apps and games on
overall design on quality and on user
experience and we're now going to be
using the app vital metrics to inform
whether the apps have a strong technical
perform
as well as luck would have it the Google
Play award ceremony is happening right
after this session at 6:30 over on stage
three and you're all invited
in fact you're highly encouraged to join
us it's a fabulous celebration of the
best of the best across the industry and
across your peers over the last year so
please join us I'll turn this back over
to Fergus we can wrap up thanks thanks
Joe
so we covered a lot of things today and
I hope you're excited about these 10
secrets and that you'll be refer your
other coworkers to our BuzzFeed talk
when it's posted on both speed later
only joking they won't post on BuzzFeed
but will be posted on YouTube for all
your colleagues say I enjoy it and
please take a photo of the top secrets
and send it to your team as well and I
encourage you to use these tools and
play around with the play consoles
there's a lot of tools in there we
rebranded the Play Developer console as
the play console because we realized
that there is very valuable to many
stakeholders in the organizations that
are building applications and so please
go ahead use the play console and use
the many tools that we mentioned today
to have success we're now going to open
it up to QA and Jai will also be over a
sandbox tomcee after this and tomorrow
so we got mics here in the middle of the
rows here please come up and ask us any
questions you have thank you very much
you
[Music]